hi everyone its Jared here and it's
officially April and to kick start the
month of April I've decided to go on and
eight weeks workout plans ready for
summertime and I would like you to join
me in this eight weeks workout planned
for you to achieve your goals I've
decided to call this workout the fit and
feminine workout series so we want to be
fit but still be very feminine at the
same time I've designed to workouts for
you to choose from the first workout is
the three day workout plan so this
record is good for beginners for those
of you who has just started working out
or for those of you who really can't
find time to work out but would like to
start working out and the second word
guy is called the five day workout plan
so for those of you who really want to
see result and you know you really want
to push yourself and really go all out
for it go for the five-day workout plan
go through my workout videos and this I
wish work out what you like to do in the
description box below I've listed what
workout to do for each day and what
areas to focus on this workout plan
consists of your warm up your cardio
strength workout core workout as well as
stretches at the end so decide which
workout plan works better for you
whether the three day or the five day
workout plan
decide on it commit to it and let's
start working out together for the next
eight weeks to achieve I'll go by June
okay let me share with you some of my
workout tips in order for you to achieve
your goal in the next
eight weeks the first tip its focus and
work on the major muscles in your body
in order to see quick results the major
muscles in our body are shoulders
triceps biceps chest and back that's for
our upper body and for our lower body
the major muscles are our quads
hamstrings cuffs and our glutes which is
also old bone and for our core obviously
it's our apps both lower and upper abs
obliques and also our lower back so
those are the major muscles that you
want to be focusing on when you perform
your workout every time
work on those major muscles and you will
definitely see quick and effective
results and the next tip is priority
everything in life you have to commit
and set yourself a target and work
towards the goal you need to commit
yourself and say if I want to lose
weight by June if I want to lose 10
pounds by June I need to make those
changes now not tomorrow not next week
not next month but now so make April and
May the month of changes commit yourself
set yourself a very clear goal know what
you want in the next eight weeks commit
yourself now and take action now so
right now I want you to decide whether
the three-day work up end of the 5-day
workout plan
stick and attainable for yourself and
the next tip is to focus on proper form
when you are working out do not cheat
when you're doing the squat make sure
you're doing a full squat there is no
point cheating if you are cheating in
your workout you will be cheating
yourself and there is no point if you
want to see maximum results for your
workout really push yourself as much as
you can within the period of your
workout there is no point working out
how heartedly I mean what is the point
if you were if you want to commit 30
minutes or one hour of your workout time
really go all out for it and make sure
you're performing the right techniques
because by performing the right
techniques you are targeting the right
muscles and therefore you will see
results tone up and burn fat so remember
proper technique is essential and also
in between those sets you should only be
resting about 30 seconds to one minute
long and nothing longer if you were to
rest longer than 30 seconds to one
minute we're actually doing is bringing
your heart rate back down and we don't
want that because the higher your heart
rate is the more fat you burn so try to
rest between 30 seconds to 1 minute
between exercise and in regards to time
of the day what time of the day should
you workout it's really up to you it
doesn't matter
I would suggest to work out all the time
where you feel most energetic for me I
like to work out in the morning
I like to get it over and done with and
start my day feeling really energized
after my workout but if you can't do the
morning it's not a problem do it in the
evening whatever time to fit you best go
for that time I remember when you are
working out especially when you have
just started off as hard as you should
push yourself you should always a lot
between 24 hours to 48 hours for your
muscles to recover so for example if you
were to perform upper body workout today
tomorrow focus on lower body do not
perform the same workout on the same
muscles the
stay because then you're not giving
enough time for your muscles to recover
it is important for your muscles to
recover because that's how you build
muscles I gave you strength
the next tip is to start easy and
progress this is really important
especially for those of you who is just
starting to work out so remember to
start easy let your body get used to
working out and then progress every week
remember that when you find a workout
easy that's when you need to start
adding more repetitions or use heavier
dumbbells if you don't challenge
yourself if you are still doing the same
workout as what you've done a month ago
that is not good for your muscles
because you're not challenging your
muscles and therefore you are just
entertaining your work and maintaining
your weight so remember to progress each
week add more weights add more
repetitions as you go along
and for nutritional tips remember to
count your calories know how much
calories you're currently consuming and
know how much calories you need to
consume in order for you to lose weight
do not consume more than what your body
needs and do not consume less than 1200
because if you were to consume less than
1200 what your body would do is to store
fat instead of burn fat so know your
calories count and consume the right
amount of calories and the next
nutritional tips which is really
important and essential is to start
writing your food journal start writing
what you eat every day and remember to
write it in details because by writing
your food journal you will know what you
eat and you will know how much calories
you're actually consuming right
every single thing down and another good
thing about writing a food journal is
that you will know why you eat
are you eating because you're hungry
are you eating because you're needed or
are you eating out of stress of
disappointment comfort eating those are
the emotional issues that we need to do
within our life in order to break free
from comfort eating and to achieve what
we want in our life to start organizing
your food cupboard so only five food
that you know will help you towards your
weight-loss goal so try not to buy jugs
because although you say you were trying
to limit your junk it turns us out when
it is in your food cupboard you will eat
it so reorganize your food cupboard take
away food that you know is not doing you
any good and start packing food that is
rich in nutrients and that will make you
feel good make you look good and that is
good for your body if you respect your
body your body will respect you in
return as much as you can try to eat a
healthy and balanced diet if you don't
know what it is just think fresh clean
and natural so anything that is
processed is not part of it and also
remember to drink lots of water a
minimum of two litres a day and if you
are working out you should be drinking
more water
what is so essential because sometimes
when you think you're hungry you're
actually not hungry you might just be
dehydrated so drink lots of water we
need it's quickly to tox our system and
also to help you to lose weight take our
diet cooks away and replace it with
water instead cut down your cafe replace
it with water water is good and
delicious
don't say stiffness another really
important nutritional tips is to have
your breakfast start your day right
start your day by treating your body
right and have your breakfast your body
needs the field to keep you going
throughout the whole day and if you have
your breakfast what you're doing to your
body is to activate the fat-burning
machine in your
so have your breakfast every morning to
not skip your breakfast besides working
out and eating food that's good for you
the next important point is rest rest
rest rest your body needs a minimum of
six to eight hours of rest the day
resting affects of stress and energy
level by resting what you're doing is to
lower your stress level and to increase
your energy level so remember to give
your body the rest it needs when it's
time to rest do not overwork yourself
rest sleep and enjoy it the next type is
a motivational tip if you've missed a
workout day don't be too hard on
yourself pick yourself back up and try
it in the next day I know it's difficult
for those of us just started working out
and you want to see instead a quick
result it is not easy to get into a
workout routine that is something new to
you
so if your visitor card a it's alright
because I'm back up and get back on
track they say it takes at least 21 days
to break or develop a habit so in the
next four weeks I want you to be able to
develop a healthy lifestyle for yourself
and also to really enjoy and that is my
next point you really have fun and enjoy
your workout it's not just about I need
to achieve my goal I need to achieve my
goal but it's more about the process so
along the process in achieving your goal
you need to have fun because if you
don't have fun once you've achieved your
goal when you look back it's like oh my
god that was torturous I don't want to
do that
again so always remember to have fun
remind yourself why you're doing what
you're doing what you want to achieve
and how will this make you feel and the
last point is to celebrate your
accomplishment okay once you've achieved
something once you've lost for example
five pounds in three weeks
celebrate accomplishment you deserve it
so celebrate accomplishment but that
doesn't mean picking on all the jugs and
going out for a huge buffet
okay so celebrate accomplishment and
make sure that you should your body
right and you treat yourself right so
let's go on this eight wigs fifth and
feminine workout series together and let
me know how you get on and I really do
want you to see results after the end of
eight weeks write your goals down be
clear about your goal it might be that
you want to lose weight or it might be
something as simple as you want to be
able to do ten push-ups at the end of
eight weeks
be specific be clear and start taking
action now not tomorrow not next week
but now so let's work out together and
don't forget to subscribe to my page you
like it
share this video subscribe to my channel
for more nutritional and fitness tips
you